[Music]
i think we can all agree that these are
stressful times in america
and whenever life is stressing me out i
like to take a moment
and gaze at the stars
whoa a shooting star i think i'll make a
wish on it
i wish the pandemic was over
[Music]
another one i wish i could spell
massachusetts without googling it
[Music]
i wish babies could talk on the day they
were born but all they could say was
swear words
i wish gum was a vegetable
i wish every plate of spaghetti was just
one long noodle
i wish that in the nfl after every
tackle
they had to whisper i'm sorry i did that
i love you
[Music]
i wish there was a remake of dirty
dancing where
baby lifts johnny
i wish every time you flossed a dentist
called you to say
good job
i wish everyone in the world was always
happy all the time
except ryan reynolds he knows what he
did
i wish that the sun was spicy hot
instead of hot hot
i wish that inside every fortune cookie
there was a message that said
look behind you and behind you was
another fortune cookie
oh i wish for unlimited wishes well i
wasn't ready
i wish that under there we go i found
you
i wish that under my desk right now
there was a giant milkshake
there is oh
whoa my wish came true
[Music]
i also wished for farts that was a fun
little break
but now let's get to talking about the
news
gonna be so sick just a little bit more
amber don't my husband won't let me have
this
[Laughter]
and then i cry and say owie my belly and
then i fart
you